en Georgia las marchas de mujeres se
mezclaron con las marchas en contra de
la ley de los agentes extranjeros con
miles de personas protestando en la
capital el proyecto de ley exige a las
organizaciones que reciben más del 20%
de su financiación del extranjero que se
registren como agentes extranjeros una
forma según el gobierno de luchar contra
las organizaciones extranjeras que
trabajan en contra de los intereses del
estado
Hoy se suponía que iba a haber una
marcha de mujeres que se concentraría en
los problemas de las mujeres pero ahora
nos enfrentamos a una ley rusa que ayer
votaron en primera instancia y ahora
Estamos protestando contra la ley rusa
que el gobierno georgiano está
intentando tomar y arruinar el país
estamos aquí y estamos dispuestos a
luchar para demostrar lo que Georgia
realmente quiere queremos un futuro
europeo
los georgianus que son ampliamente
antimoscú califican el proyecto de ley
rusa por lo que el kremlin adoptó una
ley similar en 2012 que usó para
reprimir la oposición y los medios de
comunicación la sociedad acusa al
partido sueña georgiano que lidera el
gobierno y tiene la mayoría en el
parlamento de mantener lazos demasiado
cercanos con Moscú y de usar a menudo la
represión esta legislación alejaría
Georgia de la posibilidad de acceder a
la Unión Europea el país desea
convertirse en candidato oficial de la
organización pero el año pasado Bruselas
rechazó esta posibilidad alegando que
debía primero hacer reformas sobre el
estado de derecho